Es ist schon krass:
Wenige Minuten Fussweg
von meiner Wohnung entfernt,
mitten in Chur,
gibt es eine offene Drogenszene.
Anscheinend sogar die grösste
offene Drogenszene der Schweiz.
Zwei, vier, sechs.
Vier Tage bin ich in die Drogenszene
des Stadtgartens in Chur eingetaucht.
Mit der Frage: Was und wer verbirgt
sich hinter den Parkmauern?
Das ist mein zweites Zuhause.
- Es beginnt schleichend.
Man merkt es gar nicht
und plötzlich bist du mitten drin.
Mit Untertiteln von SWISS TXT
Ich selber habe null Berührungspunkte
mit Drogen.
Am Anfang dieser Sendung
wusste ich nicht mal,
ob ich mich traue,
in den Park reinzugehen.
Alle, die mit mir über den Stadtpark
gesprochen haben, sagten:
"Nein, geh dort nicht rein."
Das ist heavy stuff.
Ich dachte, dass es wohl ...
... nicht die beste Idee sei,
dort mit meiner Kamera
und meiner Frisur reinzugehen
und dass das wohl
etwas komisch rüberkommt.
Darum bin ich mir nicht ganz sicher,
ob ich das wirklich machen soll.
Vor dem Eingang des Stadtgartens
wurde ich sofort
von einem älteren Typen angesprochen,
der seit 40 Jahren in der Szene ist.
Er konsumiert ab und zu Heroin
und will nicht erkannt werden.
Ich habe Angst, dass ich
zu snobby bin, wenn ich sage,
dass ich da nicht reingehe.
- Okay.
Was machst du denn?
- Ich gebe dir einen Tipp:
Klär das erst ab,
wenn du etwas machen möchtest.
Lass die Kamera im Auto
und geh so rein!
Frag sie, wie es aussieht!
Sie werden dich nicht verprügeln.
Ist meine Angst grundsätzlich ...
- Das ist ja logisch.
Du bist ja nicht einer von ihnen.
Du hörst immer nur von Brutalität,
dass sie dich verprügeln
und dir das Portemonnaie stehlen.
Es ist nicht ganz so.
Das ist nur bei einigen so,
die zu viel basen,
einfach zu viel Kohle drin haben
oder denen es sowieso egal ist,
weil sie ausgeschafft werden.
Aber von denen hat es nicht viele.
Oder jene, die finden: "Fuck ab!"
Von denen hat es auch nicht viele.
Die meisten sind eigentlich ...
- Patschifig? Bündner Style?
Ja, ja, patschifig.
Sagen wir es so: patschifig.
Okay.
Vielen Dank.
Du hast mir mental geholfen.
Kein Problem.
Er hat mir die Angst
ein bisschen genommen.
Er sagt, dass es nicht
so schlimm sei, wie alle sagen.
Vielleicht ...
... ist das seine Sicht
und nicht unbedingt die richtige.
Das finde ich raus,
wenn ich endlich reingehe.
Mit Kamera und allem
gehe ich aber besser nicht rein.
Es ist lustig:
Nur schon beim Fotografieren
fühlte ich mich mega beobachtet.
Ich dachte, es würde jemand
mit einem Messer rauskommen.
Ich bin so ein Snob.
Dass Leute im Stadtgarten
öffentlich Drogen nehmen,
ist immer wieder in den Medien.
Es herrsche
auch eine aggressivere Stimmung,
seitdem gewisse Drogen
genommen werden, hört man.
Aber bald könnte
die offene Drogenszene verschwinden.
Die Politik will etwas unternehmen.
Ein Konsumraum
ist seit Langem im Gespräch.
Die Stadt Chur
finanziert ausserdem seit
rund einem Jahr die Streetworker.
Ich darf sie bei einer Tour in
die Stadt, in die Szene, begleiten.
So ...
* Kirchenglocken *
Klassisch Chur: bergsteigen.
Wir sind zum Verein Überlebenshilfe
unterwegs.
Sie ...
... haben Sozialarbeiter,
die regelmässig ...
... in den Stadtpark, aber auch
in die Nähe des Bahnhofs gehen,
um den Leuten, die dort verkehren,
zu helfen.
Romina Beeli und ihr Team machen alle
zwei Tage so eine Runde in die Stadt.
Was machst du?
Vor und nach jedem Dienst ...
... überprüfen ich und mein Team,
dass die Taschen vollständig sind
und die Dinge enthalten,
die wir jeweils mitnehmen.
Z.B. diese Safeboxen.
Ich kann eine öffnen.
Sie enthält
sauberes Spritzenmaterial.
Alkoholtupfer,
Nadeln in verschiedenen Dicken
und was man so braucht.
Was man braucht,
wenn man intravenös konsumiert.
Wir haben
eine kleine Apotheke dabei,
weil wir auch Wundbehandlung machen.
Wir haben auch
unsere Streetwork-Zigaretten dabei.
Was ist das denn?
* Lachen *
Das ist ... ähm ...
Die verteilen wir ab und zu.
Wenn jemand keine Zigaretten hat und
danach fragt, geben wir eine davon.
Wirklich? Ist das moralisch ...
Also, weisst du ...
Ich rauche selber nicht mehr.
Aber ein Zigarette ...
Manchmal passt es einfach.
Wenn jemand mega frustriert ist
oder mega aufgebracht,
sage ich oft:
"Jetzt rauchen wir erst mal eine."
Die Taschen
sind vorne so angeschrieben.
D.h., dass sie uns auch erkennen,
wenn wir kommen.
Am Anfang war die Skepsis
schon deutlich grösser.
Da war natürlich die Frage, ob wir
mit der Fahndung zusammenarbeiten.
Diese Fragen haben sich jetzt
eigentlich ziemlich beruhigt.
Ich würde privat
nie in den Stadtpark reingehen,
weil sich das komisch anfühlen würde.
Ist das berechtigt
oder bin ich da versnobt?
Aus meiner Perspektive
ist es nicht berechtigt.
Aber ich verstehe es trotzdem.
Ich kenne selber viele Leute,
die ihr Leben lang
in Chur gewohnt haben ...
Das sind Geschichten
über den Stadtpark,
die von Generation zu Generation
weitergetragen werden.
Das wird vielfach
nicht mehr hinterfragt.
Man geht einfach nicht
in den Stadtpark.
Ich schalte die Kamera jetzt aus,
denn da vorne ist der Stadtpark.
Ich schaue mal ...
... ob ich jemanden finde,
der mit mir spricht ...
... und sich dann auch filmen lässt.
Also.
Wir sind drin.
Die Stimmung im Park ist entspannt.
Ungefähr 15 Leute
sitzen in einer Ecke des Parks.
Der Rest ist leer.
Es habe rund 90 bis 100 Stammgäste,
sagt Romina.
Sie kämen aber unterschiedlich
regelmässig in den Park.
Dass das die grösste
offene Drogenszene der Schweiz ist,
lässt sich übrigens nicht belegen.
In vielen anderen Städten
werden solche Gruppierungen
aber nicht geduldet.
Ich habe das Gefühl,
sie seien total abgelenkt.
Du kannst etwas fragen
und dann sind sie sofort wieder weg.
Es waren jetzt auch relativ
viele Leute wirklich am Konsumieren.
Dann ist der Fokus natürlich
nicht bei dir oder bei mir.
Dann sind sie natürlich schon ...
... am Konsumieren.
Aber ich fand, dass sie
ziemlich gut reagiert haben.
Eigentlich sehr offen.
- Ja.
Noch mal im Park
darf ich Hände filmen.
Gesichter nicht.
Alle konsumieren - vor mir.
Es ist ihnen scheissegal.
Was machst du da?
- (Frau) Stahlwolle abbrennen.
Spritzen
sehe ich übrigens keine einzige.
Die meisten rauchen
diese kleinen, weissen Steine.
Filmst du jetzt?
- Ja. Ist das gut? - Mhm.
Base -
Kokain, aufgekocht mit Ammoniak.
Das sei momentan
die gängigste Droge in der Szene
und ziehe auch viele neue,
junge Leute in den Park.
Heroin habe es auch.
Von anderen Drogen höre ich nichts.
Jetzt muss ich rauchen, aber das ...
So, das war er,
mein erster Besuch im Stadtpark.
Ähm ... Die Bilanz ist durchzogen.
Niemand
wollte wirklich mit mir reden.
Ich kann das auch verstehen.
Wer will schon im Fernsehen
über seine Drogensucht sprechen?
Es braucht wohl noch
einen Vertrauensaufbau.
Was auch noch interessant war:
Um den Mittag herum
kamen plötzlich zwei Touristen
aus Lausanne mit ihrer Pizza rein
und setzten sich auf eine Bank.
Und alle Stammgäste des Stadtparks
schauten so.
Die verstanden natürlich
nicht wirklich, was da läuft.
Ja, das beweist: Wenn man
nicht weiss, was dort abläuft,
kann man locker reingehen,
ohne gebissen zu werden.
Der nächste Tag.
Mein Ziel: Jemanden zu finden,
der mit mir spricht.
Ueli hat Lust.
Er ist schon seit
30 Jahren in der Szene unterwegs.
Er kommt täglich hierher.
Ja, es gefällt mir einfach.
Ich schaue jeweils, wer hier ist.
Wenn ich den einen oder anderen
treffe, gehe ich zu ihnen hin.
Dann spreche ich mit ihm und frage,
wie es geht.
Wir haben viele Ausserkantönler,
die also nicht
aus dem Kanton Graubünden sind
und dort drin konsumieren.
Es gab zwischendurch
auch viele Streitereien.
Es ist immer dasselbe Problem:
Es geht um Drogen und um Geld,
wenn jemand nicht bezahlt.
Dann gibt es manchmal
schon ein bisschen ...
... Krawall oder Schlägereien.
Aber das ist nicht jeden Tag gleich.
Das ist unterschiedlich.
Er meint,
die offene Drogenszene gebe es nur,
weil es keinen Konsumraum gebe
wie in anderen Städten.
Er würde sich
so einen geschützten Raum wünschen.
So, neuer Tag, neues Glück.
Heute ist es mega fresh hier in Chur.
Also nicht unbedingt
der gemütlichste Tag,
um in einem Park zu hängen.
Ich bin gespannt darauf, wer da ist.
Das Krasse ist, dass ich immer noch
Respekt habe, reinzugehen.
Es braucht schon Mut,
mit ihnen zu sprechen.
Auch heute wird wieder gebaset.
Warte schnell! Warte schnell!
Die Leute sind nervös.
Gewisse suchen sogar
nach kleinen Base-Steinchen,
die hätten
auf den Boden fallen können. Krass.
Das Rauchen von Basen
ist gefährlicher
als das Schnupfen von Kokain.
Der Wirkstoff gelangt innerhalb
von Sekunden in die Blutbahnen
und der Konsum kann zu einer schweren
psychischen Abhängigkeit führen.
So ein Scheiss!
- Achtung!
Leider dauert der Flash von Base
nur einige Minuten.
Deshalb sind alle gestresst,
um den nächsten Flash zu haben.
Ein kleiner Stein
kostet aktuell 10 Fr.,
ein grosser 20 Fr.
Und übrigens: Die Drogendealer
stehen in diesem Moment neben mir.
Sie sprechen auch ziemlich offen
und vertrauen mir inzwischen -
mehr als ich gedacht hätte.
Die Einzigen, die nicht hier sind:
die Polizei.
Ich rechne jeden Moment mit ihnen,
aber ich glaube,
ich bin der Einzige, der daran denkt.
Die Drogendealer laden mich sogar
zu sich nach Hause ein.
Plötzlich stehe ich in einem
leeren Zimmer mit viel Platz,
um Base aufzukochen.
Sie brauchen mehr
für ihre Kunden im Stadtpark
und v.a. für sich.
Das Gespräch
haben wir übrigens nachgesprochen.
Du kannst jeden Dealer fragen:
Zu zweit
kannst du keinen Gewinn machen.
Wenn ich alleine wäre
oder sie alleine wäre,
würden wir etwas Gewinn machen.
Weil wir aber zu zweit sind,
haben wir keine Chance.
Man animiert sich zum Rauchen.
Normal rauchen sie ...
Ich sage mal, die, die viel rauchen,
rauchen am Tag 200 Fr.
15 Züge pro Tag.
Wir rauchen alle zehn Minuten einen.
Jetzt haben wir das etwas reduziert.
Aber eine Weile war es sehr prekär.
Wir schafften es auch schon,
alle fünf Minuten zu rauchen,
weil der Druck auch so hoch ist.
Du hast nach der Angst gefragt.
Wir haben keine Angst
vor den Leuten
und vor den Bullen auch nicht,
aber Respekt, denn das sind Profis.
Was sind das für Leute im Stadtpark?
- Durchmischt.
Vom Studierenden zum Obdachlosen
bis zum Anwalt.
Es gibt wirklich alles.
Das ist kein Klischee.
Es hat auch Ärztinnen.
Ich habe schon einen Arzt
rausgelassen.
Base ist so:
Wenn du einmal probierst,
bist du einfach fasziniert.
Wie ist das vom Charakter her?
- Sie werden zu Betonblöcken.
Du hast kein Gefühl mehr.
Ein Teil jedenfalls.
Andere haben viele Gefühle
und flennen nur noch.
Sie wollen dann
nur noch Liebe geben.
Andere würden dich
für einen Stein abstechen.
Wenn sie dich ansehen,
siehst du es in ihrem Blick:
Diese Person
will dir nur das Zeug wegnehmen.
Wie hat sich das in den letzten
Jahren im Stadtpark entwickelt?
Die Szene? Eklig.
Früher war es eine Gemeinschaft.
Jetzt achten alle nur noch darauf,
wie man profitieren kann.
Jeder achtet auf seinen Vorteil.
Beste Freunde
prügeln sich für einen Zug.
Was machen wir mit dem Stadtpark?
- Der Stadtpark?
Den heben sie am besten
mit einer Drohne aus
und setzen ihn irgendwo hin,
wo er nicht stört.
Ich weiss nicht. Es gibt Leute,
die seit 30 Jahren dort sind.
Wir stören niemanden
und tun niemandem was.
Sie können reinkommen.
Es ging noch nie jemandem schlecht.
Sie kommen ja am Mittag.
Am Mittag hat es Leute.
Da passiert niemandem was.
Fühlst du dich nicht gestört?
- Von den Leuten? Nein.
Sie fühlen sich gestört.
Wir sind froh,
wenn auch mal normale reinkommen.
Der Park ist ja für alle.
Fühlt ihr euch hoffnungsvoll?
Ja. Wenn die Hoffnung stirbt,
können wir uns direkt erschiessen.
Wenn ich denke,
ich müsse nur noch das hier machen,
was ich jetzt mache -
ob als Dealer oder als Süchtiger -,
dann würde ich mich erschiessen.
Die ganze Zeit
nur dem Zeugs nachzurennen ...
Wir rennen dem ja nur hinterher.
Ich bin total überrascht
von der Offenheit,
von der Offensichtlichkeit
dieser offenen Drogenszene.
(Mann) Kantonspolizei Graubünden.
- Grüezi, Herr Walser.
Es wäre kein Problem für die Polizei,
um einzugreifen.
Wie kann es sein,
dass sie nichts macht?
Das ist ja illegal.
Wieso macht man da nichts?
Das ist ... äh ... Das ist ...
Das ist Ihr Eindruck.
Das kann ich nicht bestätigen.
In dem Fall
scheint es so zu sein ...
Unsere Leute
haben sich wohl verpasst.
Die Kantons-
wie auch die Stadtpolizei
ist regelmässig im Stadtpark
und führt Kontrollen durch.
Sie müssen sich das so vorstellen:
Die Leute,
die sich dort drin bewegen ...
... kennen uns unterdessen
schon alle.
Mehrheitlich.
So wie unsere Leute sie auch kennen.
Ja.
- Wenn man sagt,
man mache einmal pro Tag
eine Kontrolle,
wäre das ja völlig falsch.
Ich kam in diesen wenigen Tagen
auch mit Drogendealern in Kontakt.
Ich hätte nie gedacht, dass ich
mal einen Drogendealer treffe.
Sogar sie sind sehr ...
Sie sind dort.
Ich habe sie dort gesehen
oder gemerkt, dass es wohl einer ist.
Es hat mich mega überrascht,
dass das so ...
... ja, offensichtlich ist.
Ja, also ...
Wir, also die Kantons-
und die Stadtpolizei ...
... haben auch festgestellt,
dass das Ganze dort
wieder etwas aufflackert, oder?
- Ja.
Wenn wir bei einer Polizeikontrolle
Personen feststellen,
die Betäubungsmittel konsumieren,
besitzen oder dealen ...
... werden diese ausnahmslos
zur Anzeige gebracht. - Ja.
Aber wir können nicht jeden ...
... der in diesen Bereich reinfällt,
verhaften.
Der kann von uns
grundsätzlich entlassen werden
und ist fünf Minuten später wieder
im Stadtpark und macht weiter.
Es ist eine Never-ending-Story.
Wahrscheinlich.
- Das kann man fast so sagen.
Okay.
- Vielen Dank.
Schönen Tag. Ade.
- Gleichfalls. Danke. Ade.
Gestern ...
Gestern war ich
bei einem Drogendealer zu Hause,
was eine
sehr interessante Erfahrung war.
Es fiel mir erst im Nachhinein
auf ...
... dass er eine
etwas andere Geschichte erzählte,
als alle anderen bis jetzt -
nämlich, dass es z.T. schon ...
... relativ hart
zu- und hergehen kann.
Wovor viele Leute Angst haben,
da ist vielleicht etwas dran.
Es ist nicht an der Tagesordnung,
aber brutale Dinge können passieren.
Definitiv.
Heute spreche ich mit jemandem, der
wegen Drogen auf der Strasse lebte.
Wie? Lia? Elias?
- Elia.
Elia. Super.
Frag einfach,
wenn du etwas wissen willst.
Wohin gehen wir?
Jetzt gehen wir auf den Hof
beim Bischofssitz oben.
Dort zeige ich euch, wo wir
eine Weile lang übernachtet haben.
Obdachlos in Chur -
für mich unvorstellbar.
Für ihn war es harte Realität.
Vor zwölf Jahren arbeitete er
als Chauffeur im Unterland.
Er verlor seinen Führerschein
und ab da ging es bergab.
Er verlor den Job und die Wohnung
und rutschte in die Drogen rein.
Damals, als ich keine Wohnung hatte,
rauchte ich Heroin.
Ja.
- Genau. Das brauche ich nicht mehr.
Davon bin ich zum Glück los.
Ich brauche auch keine Substitution.
Aber jetzt ... ist Spacen ...
Ja.
- Ja.
Es ...
... beginnt schleichend.
Man merkt es gar nicht.
Und plötzlich bist du mittendrin.
Der Bischof wohnt irgendwo hier.
Hier vorne hat es ...
... ein WC -
ein grosses Behinderten-WC.
Das ist im Winter auch geheizt.
Mehr oder weniger.
Und dann, ja ...
Dort schliefen wir jeweils.
So ab 23 Uhr, 24 Uhr
musste man keine Angst haben,
dass jemand kommt.
Um 5 Uhr, 5.30 Uhr musste man
aufstehen, weil die Putzfrau kam.
Es war eine komische Zeit,
wenn man darüber nachdenkt.
Es ist komisch-romantisch
in Erinnerung.
Wir zwei gegen den Rest der Welt.
Das klingt blöd, aber ...
Ja, genau.
Es sieht immer noch gleich aus.
Hier auf dem Boden
schliefen wir jeweils.
Wenn es wirklich kalt war,
brauchten wir viele Papiertücher.
Wir legten sie aus und legten die
Decke und den Schlafsack darüber.
Hier hat es eine kleine Heizung.
Ja, sie ist ziemlich heiss.
Aber es ist immer ein Stress.
Es kann immer jemand kommen.
Die Polizei macht Stichproben
und dann musst du wieder weg.
Es liegt schon an der Person selber,
eine Wohnung oder Arbeit zu suchen.
Aber es ist nicht ...
Niemand schläft mit Absicht,
aus Faulheit
oder weil er es gerne macht
draussen.
Da stecken immer Geschichten
und Schicksale dahinter.
Ja.
Hättest du mir vor ...
... zwölf Jahren gesagt, dass ich
irgendwann mal harte Drogen nehme,
geschweige denn keine Wohnung habe,
also obdachlos bin,
hätte ich gesagt: "Niemals.
Unmöglich. Das passiert nicht."
Aber es ist trotzdem passiert.
Hast du dir nie überlegt,
nach Hause zur Family zu gehen?
Das wäre schon möglich gewesen.
Aber ich hatte meine Freundin.
Wir sind immer noch zusammen.
Aber ich schämte mich auch.
Ich kann meine Schwestern
oder meine Mutter anrufen.
Es wäre kein Problem,
dort zu bleiben.
Aber das wollte ich nicht.
Man schämt sich halt auch.
Jetzt haben wir
eine Wohnung in Chur.
Sie arbeitet,
ich bin noch beim Sozialamt.
Ich möchte auch wieder arbeiten.
Das würde mir guttun.
Es zieht ihn immer wieder
in den Stadtgarten.
Das sei sein soziales Umfeld,
er habe keine anderen Kontakte.
Vielleicht auf einem Stuhl.
- Nicht auf einer Bank?
Zurück im Stadtgarten
treffe ich eine Frau.
Ich habe in den letzten Tagen
schon ein paarmal mit ihr gesprochen.
Wie findest du es, dass ich
einen Film über den Stadtpark mache?
Ich finde das gut.
Ich finde es gut, dass du nicht
einfach reinkommst und filmst,
sondern uns fragst.
Man merkt,
dass es dich interessiert.
Du kamst nicht rein
und wolltest einen Film machen,
sondern du bist
auf die Leute eingegangen.
Es interessiert dich wirklich.
Letztens kam eine Schulklasse rein.
Das fand ich verdammt schräg.
Mein Kollege und ich gingen
an ihnen vorbei und fragten:
"Ihr wisst aber schon,
was wir hier machen?"
Es war eine Schulklasse
mit einem Lehrer.
Da kommt man sich wie im Zoo vor.
Das nächste Mal werfen sie uns
noch Popcorn hin oder so.
Was bedeutet der Stadtpark für dich?
Was ist er für dich?
Er ist mein zweites Zuhause.
Meine Mutter war schon hier.
Ich kenne das alles so.
Das ist ja auch krass,
dass schon deine Mutter in all dem
drin war. Oder wie war das?
Ja, sie hatte halt viele Freunde.
Ja.
Starb sie auch an den Drogen?
Alkohol.
- Alkohol.
Macht dir das keine Angst?
Nein.
Wenn Leute - Churer, Touristen,
wer auch immer - den Film sehen ...
Also, sie klicken "grösste
offene Schweizer Drogenszene" an:
Was möchtest du, das sie wissen?
Was sollen sie von diesem Gespräch
oder Film mitnehmen?
Dass es bei uns
nicht gefährlich ist,
dass wir keine bösen Menschen sind.
Wir lassen sie in Ruhe,
solange sie uns in Ruhe lassen.
Wenn sie etwas wissen wollen,
sollen sie fragen.
Und ... Ja.
Es sind zwei Wochen vergangen,
seitdem ich mit der Frau
und den anderen gesprochen habe.
Ja, das blieb mir alles.
Was mir v.a. blieb,
also, was alle gesagt haben:
Der Stadtpark
ist eine Art Zuhause für sie.
Halt unfreiwillig,
weil die Sucht bestimmt,
dass sie immer wieder dorthin müssen,
um ihre Drogen zu kriegen.
Die Frage, die sich auch stellt,
wenn es so einen Konsumraum gibt:
Konsumieren sie vielleicht wirklich
dort drin?
Aber chillen und leben tun sie hier.
Das ist wie ein Wohnzimmer.
Darum glaube ich nicht,
dass die Leute wegen eines
Konsumraums einfach verschwinden.
Aber ich muss sagen,
dass sie hier friedlich sind.
Ich war jetzt ein paar Tage hier
und sie waren eigentlich immer nett,
auch wenn ich gehört habe,
dass es anders sein kann.
Es könne wirklich brutal sein,
wenn es um Geld und Drogen geht.
Und du?
Würdest du dich auch hinsetzen?
Was meinst du zu dem Ganzen hier?
Schreib es in die Kommentare!
Ich freue mich auf die Diskussion.
SWISS TXT / Access Services
puretype gmbh - 2021